Bruce you can't keep doing this step out
of the shadows don't let tombstones be
your family legacy
I know you're trying to create a myth
just remember there is room for Bruce
and Batman inside that suit
too long this city has burned with
corruption and greed with Bruce's help a
vote for Harvey Dent is a vote to
finally put your foot down Vicki Vale
reporter for the Gotham Gazette is the
dent campaign soliciting votes from
Gotham's biggest crime family money gets
money i can get Harvey the mayor see or
I can pull it out from under your father
despised men like Falcone no one has
ever managed to bring him down
I haven't tried yet
come on
a fire is heading this way you must show
the world the true nature of a wade
sometimes I think this whole city's our
crime scene
a revolution is knocking on Gotham store
when there's whole thing starts make
sure you're on the right side
well then time to save the city
you
hey youtubers is charlie so happy
comic-con week new Batman telltale
trailer the game's dropping but two
weeks after comic-con so let's break it
down if you guys didn't know telltale
games just like they make a Walking Dead
narrative game they're making a game
inside the Batman universe and as you
see Harvey Dent here that looks like he
has to both very pretty looking sides of
his face you can guess that this might
be something from the long halloween
storyline that was the storyline where
he was going after the mob Sal Maroni
carmine Falcone Sal Maroni while he was
sitting on the witness stand threw acid
in his face all the different movies
have done a slightly different take on
this but I think in the most recent
iteration Aaron Eckhart's version of the
character was a pretty good
representation he's like a guy that
looks like he could be Batman but takes
a turn for the worst and becomes a super
villain instead you know like Gotham's
White Knight that was the way he was
portrayed in Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy he's a friend of bruce's
so it's very personal to him that one of
his friends has turned into a super
villain you see Catwoman show up in the
trailer so as is with the other games
like Game of Thrones telltale Walking
Dead telltale if you haven't played a
telltale Game there are different
episodes that just expand the story so
the first episode will drop this August
that'll be like you know X amount of
story then the next episode will be
released a couple months after that
they'll continue the story line Game of
Thrones was like six episodes I think
this is scheduled for at least 5 episode
it might be more than that but I'm only
seeing five so like you buy the game for
like 20 25 some odd bucks and you get
the other installments for free but most
of you have probably played some version
of a telltale Game so you know the drill
is like a $25 game it is very cutscene
heavy usually I by the steam version but
like you can buy it on consoles it's not
like buying a triple a game that's like
60 gigs on your hard drive and most of
the gameplay is relatively easy once you
get the hang of the controller scheme
but the way I would think about it is
like a mixture between a movie a video
game in an interactive comic book but
you know like in the next 10 to 15 years
we're going to see interactive comic
books anyway especially because of the
virtual reality Batman game that they're
working on this is not that that's a
completely separate thing there is a
virtual reality Batman game that you'll
be able to play with your oculus or your
HTC v or whatever gear it is that you
have but for the most part this two
phase storyline seems like it's going to
be something out of the long
Halloween like a mixture of a lot of the
things that you've been seeing recently
with the Batman mythos and if you
haven't been reading Batman rebirth like
you know the comic books that are
happening right now Bruce Wayne's kind
of mellowed out he's working with bat
woman who might show up on the DC TV
shows Supergirl in particular but you
don't need to read the comics to
understand what's going on here the look
that they're going with for the gate you
know like the art style is very Gimli
Greg Capullo Neal Adams so if you don't
know the difference between those are
basically like the biggest Batman artist
of all time Neal Adams very identifiable
as old school like 70s 80s Batman Gimli
a little bit more recently Greg Capullo
just like the latest guy to do Batman so
if you've been reading any kind of
Batman comic in the last 10 years the
artwork will look very familiar and for
those of you asking which platform this
is dropping on it'll pretty much drop on
every single platform so no worries
about that you can see episode 1
available for digital download I'll get
second that's the week that Suicide
Squad comes out what an amazing
coincidence so it should be a lot of fun
and it's relatively cheap compared to
most triple-a games like it's not a
Triple A game so definitely check it out
it should be a lot of fun if you really
want to deep cut from the comics and you
want like that Harvey Dent story just
reread the long halloween one of the
best Batman stories of all time if you
guys didn't know in related comic con
news there's going to be a whole bunch
of DC and Marvel stuff happening this
week just because it's Comic Con comes
with the territory there is a DC
giveaway that I'm doing this going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I was originally going to do
some flash season three today but then
all these trailers drop so I'm just
going to do that next then I'll do a
comic con schedule video that will just
explain what's going on what day is
going to drop the videos I may be doing
for it like all the important stuff so
look out for that and I will be doing
Batman gameplay videos on my video game
channel there's links for my twitch
channel in my bonus channel down in the
description so just check the
description it's all down there so why
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for all my comic con
previews and you can click here to learn
all about what's going on with the flash
season 3 in that new black flash thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight